The only thing worse than forgetting someone's name is calling them by the wrong one.
Learn how to lock people's names into your brain with these tricks.
You will need: deep breathing, eye contact, visualization and imagination.
Step one: Take a few deep breaths before you're introduced to someone.
When you're stressed out, the brain activates an enzyme that impairs short-term memory,...
...reducing the chances that you'll remember what you hear.
Step two: Look the person in the eye as they say their name.
Research shows that making eye contact with the speaker doubles your retention.
If you're at a party, wait until all the introductions are made before you hit the buffet.
A Yale study found that memory is best on an empty stomach.
Step three: Say the person's name out loud when you first learn it,...
...as in, "Nice to meet you, John."
Repeating the name activates the auditory part of the brain,...
...and the more senses you use the better chance you have of retaining information.
Step four: When you are told a name, say to yourself, "I will remember that his name is John."
Our brains have a filter that purges information they consider unimportant.
By giving the name extra significance, your brain will be more likely to retain it.
Exercising your brain with games like Scrabble, crossword puzzles and Sudoku...
...improves memory by strengthening neural pathways and creating new ones.
Step five: Take a tip from President Teddy Roosevelt, who was renowned for his name recall.
His secret?
Picturing the person's name written across their forehead when he was first told it.
Step six: Think up a word association that will help you recall the name.
Remember Mrs. Lion by picturing her with a mane and a tail.
Envision a guy named Arnold as the Terminator...
...especially if he's scrawny.
The sillier the association, the better it'll stick.
Did you know?
The average person forgets half of what he's heard within 30 minutes.